[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINDY BROOKS: We are
here today to talk
about improving digital
well-being, Google's approach,
and tips for developers.
My name is Mindy Brooks, and
I am a UX lead here at Google.
I focus on kids and
family as well as
the UX lead for Google Play.
With me today are
three of my colleagues,
Safia, Maggie, and Rose, all
focusing on digital well-being.
And we're here to share our
insights and tips for you
today.
So let's dive right in.
Today's conversation will be
focused on three major areas,
first of which is insights
into digital well-being,
what we've learned
from talking to users
around the world about
digital well-being,
and their thoughts
and opinions there,
our products and features
that we've launched,
as well as our ongoing
commitment in this space.
And the third is our
tips for developers,
some takeaways for you today.
So how do people feel about
their digital well-being?
As a UX lead here
at Google, I can
say that we are committed
to talking to our users
around the world
to understand what
they're thinking and feeling.
In fact, this past year alone,
we spoke to 95,000 people
to understand, what does
digital well-being mean for you?
And what we learned is it's
highly nuanced and highly
personal.
What it means for me might not
mean what it means for you.
But there is one thing
people can agree on--
that kids' digital well-being
remains a top concern.
And we hear that globally.
While parents and adults
see the many benefits
of technology for kids--
education, connection,
security-- they also
have a lot of concerns.
In fact, 84% of
parents globally report
that kids' tech usage remains
a top parenting concern.
Concerns around inappropriate
content, online safety,
bullying, and even
social skill development
are themes we hear
around the globe.
And much of that
concern is because kids
are getting devices
earlier than ever before.
How many of you have ever seen
a young child with a device?
How many of you have
noticed that kid
might be better at using
that device than yourself?
That's for me, for sure.
It's quite amazing to watch.
So parents are really
starting to wrestle with,
how do we help kids
develop healthy tech habits
and balance as they grow?
So one stat that's
very interesting
is that we know
kids in the US are
getting their first smartphone
at the age of eight.
And they're just starting
earlier and earlier.
So how do parents help
develop healthy boundaries
and balance for children?
But as you can imagine, kids
don't live in isolation,
and in fact are learning
about how to use technology
from observing families and
parents' dynamic with tech
and the rules in the household.
And so this heavily influences
how kids develop and grow.
So this year, we really
set out to understand,
what does digital well-being
mean in the family context?
And if we understand
the family context,
can it help us
inform how we create
more products for people?
So we did research
in 11 countries
with 16,000 parents,
teens, and kids.
And what we learned
across the globe
is that families live
in a state of paradox
with digital well-being
and technology.
On one hand, it brings
families together.
On the other hand,
it drives them apart.
And we often hear a phenomenon
called alone together.
You're all in the same
room, on the same devices,
but we're not talking or
connecting with each other.
On one hand, it
relaxes and destresses
after a very long day
of work or school.
And on the other hand,
it causes stress.
On one hand, it promotes
child development
through education
and information.
And on the other hand,
it can potentially
hinder child development.
On one hand, parents
think kids overuse tech.
And on the other hand, parents
can't manage it themselves.
Parents will promote usage
for education and learning,
and on the other hand,
they're discouraging usage.
"Go outside" is things
we commonly hear.
So families are living in this
state of paradox and tension
on a daily basis.
So these themes emerged
from the research
of family connection, of
stress, of child well-being,
of overuse, and a balance.
And so taking these five
things into consideration,
we really wanted
to think about what
we could build for our users
to help address these needs.
But I want to point
out one thing.
It's not just adults or
parents that we've heard from.
We hear a lot from kids
and teenagers, too.
And they frequently
point out that adults
aren't the best at modeling
balance and well-being
for them.
We hear stories of texting
at the dinner table
while the kid has to have
their phone put away,
or texting while driving,
or being distracted
and the kid having to repeat
their questions over and over.
And for kids, and teenagers
particularly, they
say it's hypocritical.
So this is something that
we take very seriously.
How do we help all
of our users start
to understand what their digital
well-being means for them?
So with that, I will
pass it to Safia
to tell you a little bit more
about what we've learned here.
SAFIA BAIG: Thanks, Mindy.
Hi, I'm Safia.
I'm a UX researcher on Android.
When we talk to adults
about their smartphones,
in particular, they tell us that
notifications can distract them
and even cause stress.
We talked to people
about notifications
and how they manage
their attention.
And they tell us
they're afraid to miss
important notifications,
and they're so
inundated with
notifications, but only some
are actually important.
In one of our studies,
a research participant
said, "Notifications make
us attached to our phones.
It's horrible."
But notifications are just one
element of digital well-being
on smartphones.
Across studies, we
started to hear a growing
resentment towards phones.
For example, someone said,
"It's almost inhumane
to always have a
phone in my hands."
And someone else said, "I
look at this thing more
than anything else in my day,
even more than my girlfriend."
Than we were in Japan
doing some research,
and we talked to
feature phone users.
So they were actively
avoiding using a smartphone,
and they were happy.
A feature phone user said,
"Other people on smartphones
are on social networks,
and they feel the need
to be connected ALL the time.
I don't want to live like that.
I have a clear rhythm in life.
I have self-control.
I have time for other things."
And they really inspired
us to think about JOMO,
or the Joy Of Missing Out.
And the joy comes from feeling
like you're in control,
and you're not really missing
out on anything at all.
So we decided to dig deeper into
the experience of connection
and disconnection.
We went out and talked to
people about their smartphones.
And they repeatedly tell us
just how useful and essential
their phones are.
People rely on their phones
for communication, navigation.
Phones can be our alarm
clock, our camera,
even the way that
we pay for things.
And this alone may seem
obvious, but it's actually
the implications of this that
are important to think about.
If someone does want to
disconnect from the phone,
it's very difficult to
do so because they still
need these things.
So if phones are so
useful and essential,
where does the
resentment come from?
Well, we learned that it's
unintentional behaviors
that bring about these
feelings of guilt.
So what does that mean?
It might be intentionally
using your phone for something,
and then getting
distracted and then
using it for something else.
For example, someone said, "I
check my phone to see the time
and then get sucked right in."
Or it could be spending
longer than you
intended on the device.
Someone else said, "I
spent an hour and a half
on a social media app.
I was appalled with myself."
And people tell us
about how they've
noticed their own behaviors on
their phone evolve over time.
For example, we've
heard about feeling
"phantom cues," feeling like the
phone is buzzing when it's not.
Or they notice that
they might repeatedly
refresh an app just hoping
for new content to appear.
And people say that
they're afraid to be
away from their phone in case
somebody needs to reach them,
or they get a message, and
they need to reply quickly.
So it can be very difficult
to put the phone down,
to disconnect from it.
As people are more
and more connected,
there's this desire to
disconnect, or to at least
use the phone in a
more intentional way.
So what has Google
done to support
people's intentional
relationship
with their technology?
Last year, we
stood on this stage
and announced our commitment
to digital well-being, which
is really rooted in our
belief that technology
should improve lives and
not distract from them.
We launched tools to give
people greater control
over how they use their
devices and technology.
One of those tools
is Family Link.
So, for parents, you can monitor
and keep an eye on screen time,
setting daily
limits and bedtimes.
You can manage the
content that your child
sees, remotely approving
downloads and blocking apps.
And you can keep
an eye on location,
remotely lock the device,
and for all those times
that your child loses their
phone in the couch cushions,
you can ring the device.
YouTube launched Take a Break.
So if you want to be
reminded to take breaks
while watching videos, YouTube
will send you a reminder.
Gmail launched Snooze.
So if you want to put
emails off for a later time,
you can do that.
And they launched-high
priority notifications,
so you only get notified when
there's an important email
in your inbox.
And we've seen that
high-priority notifications
have eliminated 97%
of notifications
on average, while still
keeping users up-to-date
when they get an important
email from the people that
matter most.
On Android, we launched digital
well-being tools, including
the dashboard, which shows you
how you're using your device;
app timers, which let
you put limits on apps;
and Wind Down to
help you disconnect
from the device at night.
And in one study, we've
seen that app timers helped
users stick to their
goal 96% of the time,
and Wind Down reduced
nightly use by 27%.
So we're starting to see
the impact of our features,
but we know that
there's more to do.
I'm going to pass
it over to Maggie.
MAGGIE STANPHILL: Thank you.
In my role, I look across
Google's digital well-being
initiatives to
align our strategy
and ensure that we have
a point of view that
shares a user's point of view.
And what we heard this year
is that many people have
digital well-being
on their minds,
and it's become
even more important
for people and their
families around the world.
As you heard from
both Mindy and Safia,
we know that helping parents
is critical to this initiative.
So with our launches of
Family Link for mobile as well
as on ChromeOS devices,
we've brought the support
to our global users.
And in the past 12 months,
we've seen one in three people
actively take steps to make a
change with their relationship
with tech.
And the interesting thing
is that these people
have taken steps that I
have certainly taken myself,
things like deleting apps
I'm not actively using,
or reducing the number
of notifications,
and finally sometimes leaving
that phone in a different room
in order to not be interrupted.
And the good news
is that 80% of them
have reported a positive impact
to their overall well-being.
This is really,
really hopeful news,
but we know that we can do
even more together, which
is exactly why we're here with
you, our developer community.
You can help us really
scale this together.
Another resource
that we've leveraged
is drawing upon the
expertise of others.
So we've assembled a bunch
of experts in various fields,
ranging from neuroscience,
to behavioral science,
to psychology and parenting,
and we're employing their best
practices in a lot of our work.
For me, as a user
experience practitioner,
I love to think about the user.
It's a great way to
ground us in empathy.
And so with the many--
in fact, 95,000-- people
we listened to this year,
I thought I would share with
you a little bit about how
they're feeling about this
topic in their own words.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Oof.
- I feel like I should
be controlling it.
- My biggest issue with it
is knowing when to stop.
- It just tends to
capture me away from what
I should be focusing on.
- I think you have to say
that you control the phone.
It doesn't control you.
- Technology is-- not so much
that it's a necessary evil,
it's a necessary good
that could go either way.
You know, the jury's out.
It's up to us as to what
we do with the technology.
[END PLAYBACK]
MAGGIE STANPHILL: So you
heard from our wise users.
The jury is out to us, up
to us to really determine
what's next.
And with that, we're
going to introduce
some of our awesome
features which
built in a lot of the insights
we learned from our users
through these many studies.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Rose
to share some of these updates.
ROSE LA PRAIRIE: Great.
Thank you.
MAGGIE STANPHILL: Yep.
ROSE LA PRAIRIE: Hi, I'm
Rose, product manager
for digital well-being.
And as we've heard from
Safia, and Mindy, and Maggie,
we have been making
a lot of progress.
We're encouraged to
see the data, which
shows our users are really
changing their behaviors
and meeting their goals,
but also, our research
tells us there's
more work to do.
So we're excited to announce
some new features which
continue to build on what
we announced last year.
First, as we heard,
notifications
can be a source of stress.
So there's a whole
bunch of stuff
that my phone will tell me
that's really useful, but not
all of it is useful right now.
For example, this morning
I was working out.
And before anyone
thinks I'm a hero,
I'm on London time, so I'm
basically in the afternoon
right now.
And I'm sitting in a plank,
and I'm watching the timer,
hoping that timer's
going to go down quickly,
and I get the
notification that says,
hey, the daily
crossword's ready.
And I love my crosswords, but
right then, I didn't need that.
So in Android Q, what
we're introducing
is priority notifications.
And what this does is creates
two types of notifications.
There's priority,
and there's gentle.
And only the priority
notifications
will make noise or
vibrate and interrupt you.
So, in my example,
that crossword
notification, that can
be gentle and something
I come back to later as
opposed to interrupting me
right now in the moment.
And we've learned
from the research
that it's the
unintentional moments that
can lead to feelings
of regret and guilt.
So there are important
moments in your day
when your phone should
reflect the intention of what
you're trying to do.
With Wind Down, we
do that at night,
so that when the
user's trying to sleep,
Wind Down serves as a
reminder that that's
what you're trying to do.
But imagine I'm at
work or at school,
and I want to be productive.
There's a lot of
stuff on my phone
that can help me be productive.
If I'm at work,
I'm getting emails.
I'm looking up where
my next meeting is.
I'm getting pings.
There's a multitude of things.
But there's some stuff
that would be better
to wait until when I
don't need to focus.
So we're introducing
focus mode, which
will let you pause distracting
apps with a single tap
to get work done.
When the app is paused, the
notifications are paused,
and you can't open the app.
So, for example, when
preparing for this speech
or trying to do work at work,
you can turn on focus mode
to pause the apps that actually
you don't need at that moment.
And we've seen
that our app timers
are effective for
helping users be
more mindful of
the apps they maybe
want to use at different times.
But we've heard a lot
of feedback from people
all around the
world that it's not
just apps that distract
them, it's also websites.
So, for example, one that
I can personally relate to,
that feeling of,
oh, I'll just go
and maybe do some
online shopping
or scroll these news sites.
And so what we're
doing in Android Q
is we're introducing
the ability for you
to see your data
from Chrome and also
to set timers on not just
apps, but also websites.
But changing habits is hard.
I always remind
myself of this when
it feels like work is hard.
And what we've
heard from users is
that they want more positive
encouragement and motivation
to stick to their goals.
So you'll start to
see more of this,
starting first with the
ability to set a screen time
goal with helpful
nudges to stay on track.
And as Maggie mentioned,
we're doing this partnering
with many experts to
understand more how do
we think about user behavior.
And in addition to
these new features,
we're also making a
number of improvements
to existing features
to make sure
that they continue to
be effective and help
users achieve what
they want to achieve.
So, for example,
we're making it easier
to see how you're doing
with your app timers,
and we're introducing a
daily schedule for Wind Down
because as much as we
might hear from the experts
that it's really
important you go
to sleep at the exact
same time every night,
we know that that doesn't
always fit in your life.
And we know from our research,
and we heard from Mindy,
that parents are concerned
about the amount of time
that their kids are
spending on technology,
and they're actively
looking for support.
So we're adding more
features to Family Link
to help parents set the
digital ground rules
and find the right balance
of technology for their kids.
As one example, we're
introducing app-specific time
limits so that parents
can say, instead of
just I don't want you
used to your phone,
but I have this limit
for a specific app, which
great if you use it this amount,
but beyond that, we'll shut it
down for the rest of the day.
And we're also introducing
the ability for parents
to grant kids more screen time.
So imagine your kid
reaches their screen time
limit for the day but has a
little more homework to do
or something else.
Parents can grant
bonus time to the kids.
And we'll also introduce
the ability for a kid
to request bonus time, which
a parent can say yes or no to.
But it's not just parents
who have the ability
to help others disconnect.
We all have the ability to
help each other disconnect.
And so Google-- or
not Google, sorry.
Gmail just recently
launched the ability
to schedule send emails as
part of their 15th anniversary.
So, as an example, Monday was
a public holiday in the UK,
where I'm based, but it wasn't
here, so I was working here.
But my team doesn't need to
be interrupted with the emails
that I was sending.
So I can schedule
send to say I want
it to arrive on Tuesday when
they're back in the office
and not interrupt
them on the Monday.
And all of this is
helping us build
more of an intentional
way for users
to interact with
technology, so they
can meet more of their
digital well-being goals.
With that, I'll
pass back to Maggie.
MAGGIE STANPHILL: Awesome.
Thank you, Rose.
All right.
So bringing it home
with this notion
of embracing digital well-being
for a sustained relationship
with users, which I'm sure you
all are thinking a lot about as
well, and I personally
want to provide you
with some tools and resources.
This is early days
in this space,
and we'll continue to build
upon what we shared today.
But what we know is that
having a meaningful impact
really requires getting these
tools out to more people,
and you're a huge,
huge part of that.
So I want to share with
you resources for you,
resources for parents
and educators,
and resources for
you as developers.
But first, we have to
start with ourselves-- kind
of that heal thyself first
mantra that I think many of us
don't spend enough time on.
And our friends in our Google
Brand Studio and marketing team
relaunched our
wellbeing.google site.
We know that this is not a
one-size-fits-all solution,
it's very nuanced.
And so they've created a great
tool, a self-reflection tool,
a guide for parents and
kids about tech use,
and video content with
some of those experts
who we've sought out.
So I hope you'll
find this valuable,
and I hope you'll check it out.
The other thing that
we have available
is a great resource called "Be
Internet Awesome" for kids.
How many of you have
actually checked this out?
Show of hands?
All right, there's
lots of homework.
I think you guys would love it.
Three great assets within
here-- curriculum for teachers,
intra-LAN video game for kids,
and a helpful guide for parents
to have those conversations
and get kids safe
online at an early age.
And the good news, this is
available in 16 countries.
And finally, resources for you.
You are a huge, huge part
of us making this change
as a collective effort.
And so I wanted to start with
our digital well-being values.
We hold these dear, and we
build these into our products.
First, provide awareness.
We want to ensure
that we're encouraging
mindful, intentional use.
We want to then enable
control and personal ownership
so that people really
understand the decisions they're
making with their technology.
We want to then deliver
benefits without guilt, shame,
or regret.
We learned a lot of this
through the sentiment analysis
and surveys we run,
and maybe that's
an insight for you to
think about, as well.
And then we want
to ensure trust.
Ultimately, we're all here to
build that trust with users,
and this can be a critical
resource for that.
Transitioning into a
case study, the thing
that I have found so
interesting about working
on digital well-being as
a longtime user experience
practitioner is that
oftentimes what we find
is that it's what's
good for the user
is good for the well-being.
And that makes a lot of sense.
And what's interesting
about Drops--
this is a language learning app.
They use a technique
called space repetition.
And they have an
intentional amount of time
where they give a lapse between
the last learning session
and the subsequent session.
And what's interesting
is these stats
could look possibly
counterintuitive to somebody
who is looking at it from
a growth perspective.
The average daily user spends
56% less time within the app
and uses it 51% less often.
And so from a digital
well-being standpoint,
that sounds like a
really good thing.
But the amazing thing is
that this model really
lines up the user goals
with the business goals
to really make their
app strategy work.
So I'll share with you
first the user goals,
and then I'll share with
you the business goals,
and hopefully this will
convey a little bit more
about how they approached it.
So from a user
goals perspective,
they want to lower
the barrier to entry.
So they've introduced a
five-minute session limit.
They figure anybody
who's looking forward
to learning a language can
certainly spend at least
five minutes on that session.
They then want to
make sure they've got
a sustainable engagement model.
So they have a limit on the
next session, which is 10 hours.
What's cool about that is that
is that space repetition, which
really allows for
memorization, so a great way
to align those user goals
with their app strategy.
Then when we take a look
at the business strategy,
they have users who pay
more, subscribe more,
and churn less,
which is a pretty
amazing feat in and of itself.
So their stats are
also very impressive.
They see a 4x higher
average revenue
per daily user versus
their peer average.
They see a 2.5
higher install rate
to paid subscriber conversion
verse peer average.
And then finally, 84% percent
lower subscriber churn.
So this is amazing
evidence of how
you can align user
goals, business goals,
and really have a
solvent business model.
And the good news is, I'm
seeing more and more of this
in the ecosystem.
I was meeting with
top app developers
yesterday in a
developer event we had.
I'm sure many of you are also
thinking along these lines.
And I think this is what
has been so heartening to me
about this work, is
lining up the user
goals that ultimately lead
to the business goals.
I also want to share
with you best practices.
This team, this collective team
which I represent right now,
but there are many, many across
the company working on this,
have observed two critical
signals for digital well-being.
They're quality and quantity.
So let me tell you a little
bit more about quality.
So what this might look like, as
you're thinking about your app,
or maybe even reflecting on
what we just shared with Drops,
this is all about helping
them complete tasks
without completing
any extra steps.
It's also about enjoying
their time and energy spent
on the site.
And then finally, one thing
that we've really looked into
is collecting signals of
quality so that we understand
how they spent their time.
And what's interesting
about this is oftentimes,
the people in their life,
the people who matter
is a really critical signal.
And that's much of
what Rose was also
intimating with some of the
prioritization in Gmail,
et cetera.
When we look at
quantity, we want
to make sure we're encouraging
that intentional use.
So this means prioritizing
the things that help you
with your overall well-being.
That includes sleep,
work, relationships--
all those things that help your
physical and emotional self
also be well.
We then want to recommend that
if you're building enterprise
tools, you provide
some way for the user
to maybe separate that personal
life and that work life.
And I think for many of us,
it's become very intermingled,
but it's a time where
it might benefit
us to really look at ways to
break that apart at times.
And then finally,
consider the user
needs and support those needs.
This sounds like a no-brainer,
and ultimately, this comes back
to really that user
experience principle
of focusing on the user,
which we do a lot at Google.
But you might uncover
some really unmet needs
and discover some new ways
of going about your work.
Finally, again, representing
the amazing research
our team has done
across Google this year,
I wanted to synthesize
just three methods
that we have found incredibly
useful with digital well-being
research.
One, interview the
90th percentile user.
You can really get a sense
of where the unmet needs lie
when you're getting to know
who's not using your product.
Second, consult experts,
critics, and brand trust data.
Having a more
objective perspective
really helps you see
your blind spots.
And then finally, survey your
users and then check logs.
What we've seen is that through
surveys, qualitative feedback,
and surveys, that doesn't
always line up with the actions
people are taking on the
website or on the app.
So correlating those
two will really
uncover what is happening
with their user behavior.
Do they say they want
to change something,
and yet they're not
actively doing that?
And finding ways to make those
bridge is really important.
Finally, I want to thank
you, first and foremost,
for coming out very early
this morning to be with us.
I really appreciate that
you've come to Google
to spend this time together
with this amazing community.
And I hope that you'll get
outside, once it gets sunny,
and take some time to just
enjoy this amazing week,
and experience JOMO,
as we like to call it.
And when you get
back to your desk,
we look forward to
working with you
on building an ecosystem
that supports and prioritizes
digital well-being.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]